a judge investigating the Beirut Port
explosion in Lebanon in 2020 is being
summoned by lebanon's top prosecutor
Tariq blitzau has been charged with
mishandling the inquiry but he's
refusing to step down people gathered at
the Justice Palace in the capital
demanding accountability for the
disaster on Wednesday the prosecutor
also ordered the release of all those
detained in the case more than 200
people were killed in the blast when
improperly stored chemicals ignited
zinacoto's following developments from
Beirut a legal showdown between
lebanon's Chief prosecutor and the lead
judge looking into the case of the
Beirut Port explosion is now spilling
onto the streets families family members
of the victims they are angry they are
trying to storm and raid the Justice
Palace they believe that the ruling
establishment whether it's the
politicians whether it's high-ranking
security officials and even some members
of the Judiciary are trying to evade
Justice the investigation from the start
has been repeatedly stalled by political
interference in fact it was put on hold
for more than a year until a few days
ago the lead judge in the case
he decided to resume the investigation
he had been facing a number of legal
cases put forward by ministers he called
suspects and charged them with criminal
negligence he says that they have no
right to put him on the side and he
wants to continue his investigation he
charged a number of high-ranking
security officials the response from the
chief prosecutor who is of course backed
by the political establishment is that
today's orders will not be implemented
and that any decision he makes will not
be will not be taken into account but
tarabitar is standing his ground he says
he's still the judicial investigator he
will continue his investigation he will
not step down he will not appear for
summoning because the chief prosecutor
summoned him and that even if it means
that he will be locked behind bars he
will still issue an indictment so for
people here this is a battle between
right and oppressed many people have
lost their children in that class they
want answers they want to know who
brought the ammonium nitrate into the
country and stored it unsafely at the
Port Paul Jacobian is a member of the
Lebanese Parliament and she says While
most politicians in officials have tried
to delay investigations into what
happened a handful of politicians do
want to see the guilty punished
the corrupt Junta in Lebanon is trying
again to get away with all the crimes
that they're doing so we have these
criminals trying to stop the only judge
who is defending today his investigation
and
um and he is insisting to continue what
he what he started let me remind you
that there was a previous judge that is
the one who was on the same track going
in the same path and he was stopped also
by a political meddling in the Judiciary
and here again this time they're trying
to stop judge Peter but he's not
stopping right now in the parliament of
Lebanon we have a sit in an ongoing
sit-in since one week my colleague here
Dr najat Saliba and MP melchem halaf
they decided to stay in the parliament
since last Thursday and one of the
reasons is definitely to elect the
president in Lebanon but also to put on
uh on track the uh the Beirut blast and
to make sure that that Justice will be
served in this country